[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اعلن نقيب الصحفيين في مصر
اعتصاما مفتوحا للصحفيين ردا على اقتحام
قوات الامن مقر نقابتهم في سابقه تاريخيه
وطلب بيان للنقابه قاله وزير الداخليه
وحمل الصحفيون الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
المسؤوليه عما وصفوه بالجريمه غير
المسبوقه نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما الذي دفع سلطات المصريه الى
الاقدام على هذه الخطوه الخطيره غير
المسبوقه وما هي خيارات الصحفيين الممكنه
للرد على الانتهاكات المتكرره
بحقهم
تصعيد متواصل تقوم به سلطات الامن في مصر
ضد الصحفيين ونقابتهم من منعهم دخول
النقابه الى اقتحامها في سابقه تاريخيه
الى محاصرتها لا تتوقف قوات الامن عن
استخدام القوه لفرض سطوتها على نقابه
الصحفيين المصريه وسط استهجان عام من
الوسط الصحفي والنقابي ولا يبدو ان سلطات
تتجه للاستجابه لطلب الصحفيين اقاله وزير
الداخليه بعد ان اعلنت ان الصحف فيين
الذين اعتقلتهما في مقر النقابه كان
بحوزتهما اسلحه ومولوتوف وضع دفع مواقع
لبعض الصحف المواليه للانقلاب الى الاتشا
بالسواد حدادا وبعض الصحفيين الى القول ان
الصحافه في مصر دهست بالاقدام مطالبين
الرئيس ورئيس الوزراء بالاعتذار تقرير
فاطمه
تريكي الصحافه مش ارهام الصحافه مش ارهام
هل قطع النظام في مصر الشعره الاخيره مع
الصحفيين حتى وجد الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي نفسه عالقا بين تهدئه غضبهم العارم
او التضحيه باحد ابرز ادواته الامنيه من
الاحد يعتصم صحفيون داخل نقابتهم المطوقه
وناصرهم زملائهم من خارجها النقابه التي
لم تجد نفسها يوما في مثل هذه الحاله
المتقدمه من المواجهه مع نظام حكم في مصر
مع استثناء في مستوى الحريات خلال سنه حكم
الرئيس المعزول محمد مرسي فان كل من سبقوا
السيسي كانوا يتقنون الحفاظ على التوازنات
فيقفون غالبا عند حافه الهاويه وزير
الداخليه الحالي قطعها بما لم يسبقه اليه
احد عندما اقتحم ضباط امن مقر النقابه
لاعتقال صحفيين هما محمود السقه وعمرو بدر
قريب محمود بدر النائب الحالي وزعيم حركه
تمرد الم مندثره التي شكلت الواجهه
الشعبيه لانقلاب السيسي بحسب بيان
الداخليه الذي غطته من بعد النيابه العامه
فان قرارا بالضبط والاحضار صدر بحق تسعه
اشخاص بينهم الصحفيان لتهم تتصل بتظاهرات
ال من ابريل الماضي واتهم بدر والسقه ببث
اخبار كاذبه عبر وسائل التواصل والتحريض
على التظاهر وصولا الى تهمه ثقيله هي زعزع
استقرار البلاد لتعود النيابه العامه
وتضيف بعد التحقيق ان المتهمين كان معهم
اسلحه كل ذلك يشكك فيه الصحفيون التجا
الصحفيان الى مقر النقابه ظنا منهما ان
لها حرمه عاصمه لكن الامن اقتاده ما منها
الامر الذي نفته وزاره الداخليه واكدت
النقابه وشهود فاعلنت الاستنفار وابقت
اجتماعاتها مفتوحه بانتظار جمعيه عامه
الاربعاء ورفعت سقف مطالبها مسؤوليه وزير
الداخليه هي مسؤوليه سياسيه بالاساس ويجب
ان يتحمل مسؤوليتها ويجب ان تتم اقالته
كمدخل لحل هذه الازمه انه اذا صراع
الايرادات يبلغ ذروته بين كيان نقابي مهم
مدفوع براي عام بان ما جرى تجاوز لخط احمر
واهانه لا تحتمل وان كان لاخرين منطق
تعززه الوقائع يقول بان هذا النظام قد
تجاوز كل الخطوط والالوان ومنذ زمن الجديد
ربما انه بدا ياكل ابنائه وفي وقت
قياسي نرحب بضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه من
باريز محمد محسوب وزير الشؤون القانونيه
والبرلمانيه المصري السابق من القاهره عبر
سكايب المحامي والباحث السياسي اسعد هيكل
وعبر الهاتف من القاهره ايضا ممدوح الولي
نقيب الصحفيين المصريين السابق او الاسبق
نبدا بالسيد ممدوح ولي سيد ولي برايك
لماذا تجرات السلطه واتخذت هذه الخطوه في
حين لم
يسبقها اي سلطه ان فعلت
ذلك واضح انه السيد ولي لا يسمعني اذا
اتجه بالسؤال الى اسعد هيكل اساله ان ان
لماذا تجرات سلطه على النقابه بطريقه غير
مسبوقه
بتقديرك يعني لا لا لا اسير ولا اعتقد انه
يجب ان ننسب هذا الخطا الى السلطه بشكل
عام يعني من نبكر القطع من هو المسؤول عما
حدث من انتهاك في حقيقه الامر لحصانه ومقر
نقابه الصحفيين خلينا نتفق على ان هناك
خطا ماتكب ان لم يكن خطا قانوني من وجهه
نظر البعض وانا خطا قانوني تجاوز فيه
مامور الضبط القضائي
الذي اقتحم نقابه الصحفي ينفذ في حقيقه
الامر اذنا صادرا من النيابه العامه
بالقبض على الصحفي عمرو بدر وزميله لكن هو
لم يكن كذلك خطا قانونيا هو بالتاكيد خطا
سياسي اتخذ قرار من جهه ما داخل وزاره
الداخليه بالقبض على الصحفي بالعوم في
حققه الامر ولم يراعي اي تقدير سياسي ولم
يعمل الملائمه السياسيه في هذه الظروف
لكن على الصعيد الاخر هناك من خلال ما
تصرب لنا او ما علمنا من تصريح احد
الصحفيين المقربين للرئيس السيسي ان مؤسسه
الرئاسه ممتعضه لهذا الامر
وترفضه بشكل ما
وايضا على الصعيد السياسي بصفه عامه كافه
القوى السياسيه رفضت هذا التصرف لكن
المسؤوليه هنا من وجهه نظري هي مسؤوليه في
حه الامر مشتركه لا استطيع ان احمل وزير
الداخليه وحده هذه المسؤوليه باعتبار ان
هناك امرا قضائيا صدر من النيابه العامه و
حد ما ورد بقرار وزير ببيان وزاره
الداخليه في عجز هذا البيان وردت عباره في
منتهى الاهميه حيث قال البيان انه باطلاع
النيابه العامه على وجود الصحفي داخل
نقابه الصحفيين امرت بتنفيذ الازن الصادق
ب واحضره هو وزميله وبالتالي تكون
المسؤوليه مشتركه اذا كان قد حدث خرق
للقانون وع الاخص قانون نقابه الصحفيين
الذي نص في الماده 70 منه على حصانه مقرات
نقابه الصحفيين بعدم جواز دخولها وتفتيشها
الا بمصاحبه عضو من النيابه العامه وبعد
اذن نقيب الصحفيين يعني يعني عفوا طال
طالما اشرت سيد هيكل طالما اشرت السيد
هيكل الى هذه النقطه المهمه بعد اذك طالما
اشرت الى هذه النقطه القانونيه المهمه
نسال السيد محمد محسوب عن ما جرى بالطبع
هو محل استهجان سياسي وا من الاوساط
الصحفيه ولكن على الصعيد القانوني كان
هناك ايه وجاهه لما فعلته السلطه مع
النقابه تحياتي لشخصك الكريم
ولضيوفك الكرام وللمشاهدة
الحقيقه انه جوهر القانون هو المسؤوليه
تحديد المسؤوليات احنا عندنا السلطه
مسؤوليتها هي ضمان وصيانه الدستور اللي
اهم ما فيه ومحوره هو حمايه حقوق وحريات
الشعب ومؤسساته المدنيه وافراده وغير ذلك
وبالتالي المسؤوليه الاولى يجب عند اي
ناظر قانوني اي واحد بيتحدث عن مجال
القانون المسؤوليه القانونيه وليست
السياسيه تقع على عاتق من يدير البلاد اذا
حصل خرق فيما يتعلق بالحريات والحقوق
الاساسيه التي صانها الدستور وعلى راسها
الحق في الحياه وقد اهدر سابقا ومستمرين
في اهداره ثم ناتي الى حق التعبير وحريه
الصحافه اللي هي مش حق شخص ومش
حق الصحفيين الذين قبض عليهم ويقبض عليهم
كل يوم وانما هي حق المجتمع في التعرف على
الحق والوصول الى المعلومه والنقد وبناء
وجهه النظر والى ذلك النقطه الثانيه اذا
دخلنا فيما يتعلق بالمسائل الجوهريه في
الضبط والاحضار الحقيقه احنا امام خطا ليس
خطا امام جريمه واضحه النيابه العامه بغض
النظر عن ما تقوم به من ادوار في هذه
الاونه ومن توجيه اتهامات مستنده على
تقارير من الامن الوطني غير صحيحه ضبط
واحضار بسبب تلفيق تهم كحياه اسلحه وما
شابه انا شخصيا اتهمت بمثل هذه الاتهامات
واعتقد الاف من المصريين في كل التخصصات
بما فيهم الصحفيين ليسوا استثناء من ذلك
لكن القضيه عندنا واضحه تماما وزاره
الداخليه بتقول انها سالت رئيس النيابه
ورئيس النيابه قال لهم امر بالاستمرار في
التنفيذ رئيس النيابه هنا لم يامر بدخول
المؤسسه بدخول المبنى دخول مبنى دخول بيت
او دخول نقابه او ما شبه يحتاج الى اذن
خاص بوضوح ومن ثم حتى المسؤوليه القانونيه
المباشره
على ضابط على الضبط القائم بالضبط
والاحضار
والمسؤوليه على وزاره الداخليه اللي هي
القوه التي قامت بذلك مسؤوليه واضحه تماما
من الناحيه القانونيه وانا لا لا احب في
المسائل التي تتعلق بالحقوق والحريات زي
كل العالم المتحضر في الحقيقه ان يتحدث
العالم عن مسؤوليه سياسيه الامر لا يتعلق
بمسؤوليه سياسيه المسؤوليه السياسيه تنشا
عندما لا يمكن ان ينسب خطا قانوني بشكل
مباشر الى المسؤول بينما اذا كان المسؤول
هو مسؤول عن صيانه الدستور واخل بالحقوق
والحريات العامه فمن ثم احنا امام مسؤوليه
امام انتهاك للدستور واذا كانت المسؤوليه
متعلقه بالاجراءات القانونيه المتبعه
لدخول الى نقابه او غيرها او الضبط
والاحضار والقبض على الافراد فال المسليه
واضحه نعم بالنسبه لمامور الضبط القضائي
نعم اللافت في هذا الموضوع وهنا يعني نسال
السيد ممدوح الولي النقيب الصحفي المصريين
الاسبق يعني النقابه عمرها 75
سنه لاول مره يتم اقتحام النقابه مع انه
في عهد عبد الناصر كانت هناك مشاحنات في
عهد السادات في عهد مبارك حتى في عهد مرسي
القصير يعني ما الذي جعل الامر يصل الى حد
هذا الاقتحام حا بشكل لم
يسبق في ذلك
احد يعني السبب الرئيسي ان هذا النظام لم
يجد من يرضعه عندما انتهك يعني كل اشكال
الانتهاكات قام بها قام بقتل حوالي 13
اعلامي منذ مجيء هذا الانقلاب حتى الان في
السجون حوالي 87 اعلامي والصحفي حتى اليوم
اضيف لهم اثنين اليوم بالحبس الاحتياطي
اشكال الاقتحام للمنازل وللمقارنة
الذين قتلوا او الذين حبسوا هذا التقاعس
كما تسميه سيد الولي ايه هل تعتقد هو الذي
اوصل الامور الى هذا الحد لان للاسف
النقابه التي كانت مؤسسه عريقه في الاشهر
الماضيه تماهت مع السلطه بشكل كبير وكل من
يختلف سياسيا مع هذه السلطه لم تقف معه
اشرت الى هذه الارقام 13 اعلامي قتلوا و87
في السجن مع الاثنين صاروا 89 هذا التقاعس
هو الذي اوصل الامور الى هذا
الحد يعني هو احد الاسباب لانه عندما يعني
لم يهتم القائمين على الصحف القوميه بما
حدث لزملائهم الذين قتلوا او الذين
اعتقلوا هذا الامر بالطبع ساعد النظام
الانقلاب على التمادي في افعاله وهذا ساعد
يعني الداخليه على ان يعني تكذب وتستمر في
اكاذيبها في بيانها اليوم وساعد حتى
النيابه على يعني صدور امر الحبس
الاحتياطي للزميل ميلين اليوم بما يشير
الى انه يعني الطرق مسدوده يعني بين
النقابه وبين النظام قلنا نتصور على الاقل
ان يتم الافراج اليوم عن ال 87 اعلامي
كبادرة
ممتعضه كما قال هل تعتقد بان هذا يمكن ان
ان ان
يقبل اتصور ان من قتل ومن حبس ومن عذب ومن
يعني اعتقل ومن دهم المقار يعني لن يمتع
ولن يتاثر لان كل هذه التصرفات تتم بعلمه
ولتثبيت اركانه وهذا الكلام يعني لم يعد
ينطلي على الصحفيين في ظل هذه الممارسات
القمعيه التي عانوا منها طوال السنوات
الثلاث الماضيه نعم الصحفيان الذان اعتقل
من مقر النقابه لم تقع الاشاره اليهما على
انهما يمتلكان اسلحه فقط ب ايضا اتهم
بمحاوله قلب نظام الحكم نريد ان نعرف بعد
الفاصل ما هي الخيارات المتاحه امام
الصحفيين الان خاصه وانهم طالبوا باقاله
وزير الداخليه وهذه خطوه ايضا تعتبر لافته
في الصراع بين الصحفيين والسلطه لنا عوده
بعد فاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها هذا الصراع
المفتوح الان بين نقابه الصحفيين المصريين
والسلطات المصريه بعد اقتحام النقابه لاول
مره منذ
75 عاما سيد محمد محسوب يعني كسياسي
بالطبع لست صحفيا ولا اعليا يعني كسياسي
بتقديرك عندما يطالب الصحفيون باقاله وزير
وزير الداخليه هل تعتقد بان هذا الخيار
يمكن ان يجد صداه في
التطبيق الحقيقه بكل بساطه انا اعتقد ان
هذا المطلب هو مطلب في الوقت الخطا وفي
المكان الخطا لانه احنا بنتكلم على ما
يزيد ما يقترب من ثلاثه سنوات الان عدد
كبير اشار اليهم الاستاذ ممدوح الوالي من
الصحفيين معتقلين وجرى دهمهم في بيوتهم
النقابه صيرت قبل ذلك النهارده النقابه
جرى ا جرى اقتحامها وجرى اعتقال صحفيين
فيها ومن الخطا ان احنا نتكلم فقط على انه
المشكله هو اقتحام مبنى النقابه فقط وانما
اكثر من ذلك هو يعني القبض
واستيقاف صحفيين داخل النقابه معتصمين
داخل النقابه ثم توجيه هذه التهم الهزيله
اليهم احنا امام مسؤوليه واضحه للنظام لا
يمكن ان يسال في موظف في النظام الوزراء
في الدوله المصريه منذ ثه سبعه لحد
النهارده هم موظفون لا اكثر يعني هو كبير
موظفين وبالتالي لا يمكن مسائلته عن جرائم
بهذا الحجم لا جرائم القتل الجماعي ولا
جرائم التعذيب ولا جرائم اقتحام النقابات
او اعتقال اعضاء النقابات او
اعتقال المدافعين عن
الحقوق المدنيه للشعب المصري وجمعيات
المجتمع المدني كل ذلك هو مسؤوليه النظام
والمسؤليه الاولى تقع على عاتق من يدير
هذا النظام سواء راس النظام الظاهر او اذا
كانت هناك رؤوس اخرى خفيه اما اذا كانت
النقابه ستسير بنفس الطريقه السابقه
بمحاوله السير في خط في خط الوسط محاوله
عدم ازعاج السلطه وعدم استفزازها وفي نفس
الوقت محاوله
يعني محاوله تجميع غضب الصحفيين وتجاوز
هذه المشكله و تهدئتهم فاحنا في الحقيقه
سنصل الى مرحله اخرى لانه نظام واضح بيبدا
بقتل فصيل معين ثم ينتقل الى قتل كل
الفصائل يبدا باعتقالات للاسلاميين ثم
ينتقل الى اعتقالات للجميع يبدا بقتل
الصحف قتل المحامين في اقسام الشرطه ثم
بعد ذلك انتقل الى الاطباء ثم الصحفيين
فهو جس نبض في النهايه ن على ذكرذر هذ
المم للدوله المصريه ولكل العمل النقابي
وسنصل اليه ما تقف النقابات كلها وقفه
واحده في هذه اللحظه على ذكر هذه
المواجهات سيد اسعد هيكل فعلا السلطه دخلت
في اشكالات مع الاطباء مع المهندسين مع
بعض الاوساط الكرويه اخيرا دخلت في جدال
مع شرائح واسعه فيما يتعلق بترسيم الحدود
بين السعوديه و ومصر والمظاهرات الاخيره
ما الذي يجعل هذه المواجهه مع الصحفيين
حظها افضل لماذا يعتقد الصحفيون بانهم
بامكانهم ان يفرضوا شيئا لم لم يستطع
الاخرون ان ان يفرضه على
السلطه مش مساله انك انت تفرض شيء على
السلطه او ان الاخرين لم يستطيعوا يعني
انا متفق مك ان هناك انتهاكات انتهاكات
كثيره حدثت على صعيد حقوق الانسان مست
الاطباء ومست المحامين وفي الاخير مست
الصحفيين لكن لو احنا استحضرنا احد هذه
الانتهاكات على سبيل المثال حدثك الاخباء
على محامي من جانب نائب م مركز فرسكور من
حوالي ثلاثه اشهر خرج رئيس الجمهوريه
بنفسه واعتذر
للمحامي لا بالتالي لا استطيع ان احمل ما
يسميه ضيفك على الجانب الاخر خاصه الاستاذ
والي حينما وصف النظام بانه نظام انقلابي
وانا اعتقد ان هذه انتهازيه سياسيه في
حقيقه الامر لا ينبغي خلط هذه الامور هكذا
وانتها انتهاز حدث كما هو حدث الان وتوصيف
النظام بانه توصيف انقلاب الصحفين انفسهم
او البيان الرسمي لنقابه الصحفيين لم يصف
نظام الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي بانه نظام
انقلابي وان هذا يخسر طالما اشرت طالما
اشرت لهذه طالما اشرت لهذه النقطه سيد سيد
هيكل يعني بعد اذنك طالما اشرت طالما اشرت
لهذه
النقطه هذه المره تقريبا النظام يواجه
اعلاميين لم يكونوا معترضين عليه يعني
فعلا
اوسع الفئات الصحفيه كانت
[موسيقى]
متماهية ينتبه مبكرا ويصحح هذه الاخطاء
وحتى مطلب الصحفيين باقاله وزير الداخليه
انا انا شخصيا رايته مطلب لا يكفي لا تكفي
عمليه الاقاله الخطا وقع والاقاله اقاله
الوزير نفسها لم تصحح هذا الخطا حتى لو
اقل رئيس الوزراء الامر يتطلب من السيد
رئيس الجمهوريه ان ينتبه الى ان داخل
دوائر سلطاته من يعمل ضده هو شخصيا وينتقص
من شعبيته ويؤثر على مصداقيه جهزته وهذا
ليس جديل ولكن ولكن الا يقود هذا الا يقود
هذا هذا المنطق سيد هيكل سيد هيكل الا
يقود هذا المنطق اسمح اسمح لي يعني بعد
اذنك الا يقود هذا المنطق وهنا اسال سيد
ممدوح الولي المنطق المتداول في اكثر من
دوله عربيه انه انه الرئيس كويس لكن
الدائره المحيطه به الله يهديها هي التي
تدخله في في متاهات الى اي مدى هذا الامر
صحيح في مصر الان مع هذا الاشكال مع
الصحفيين يعني انا بتصور ان المسؤوليه
مشتركه وان هؤلاء يعني داعمون يعني هذا
الرئيس بتصرفاتهم عندما يعني انكروا ما
حدث مع زملائهم من قتل واعتقال وتعذيب
واحاله للمحاكم العسكريه واصابات اثناء
اداء عملهم وبالتالي المسؤوليه المشتركه
والمسؤوليه الاولى تقع على راس النظام
باعتباره هو الذي سمح بهذه الممارسات ولم
نجد له حتى في اعياد الشرطه او غيرها اي
اعتذار او اي اشاره الى اسر الضحايا سواء
من المواطنين او من الصحفيين خلال السنوات
الثلاث الماضيه ولكن هل هل يمكن هل يمكن
ان يعتذر هذه المره للصحفيين لان ليس من
مصلحه اي نظام والنظام السيسي بالطبع من
بينها ليس من مصلحته ان يخسر هؤلاء الذين
يقفون سندا له في اكثر من مناسبه اذا خسر
هؤلاء خسر جزء كبير من قطاعات من الراي
العام كانت تقف معه بسبب هذا الاعلام
السائد في مصر تحديدا يعني اتصور ان يعني
بعض انصاره سوف يقومون بتبرير الافعال
وانه بعيدا عن المسؤوليه ويعني الاتيان
بكبش فداء سواء وزير الداخليه او غيره حتى
يمر الموقف لكن اتصور ان يعني الصوره
اتضحت امام الصحفيين الذين سندوا هذا
الانقلاب وعرفوا بانه يعني يعني مض للجميع
سواء الصحفيين او سواء كافه شرائح الشعبيه
ويعني اكرر مره اخرى ان حريه المواطن يعني
ليست باقل اهميه من حريه الصحفي او
المحامي او الاطباء الكل سواء والحريه
للجميع ونطالب من هنا بالافراج عن كافه
المعتقلين السياسيين في السجون المصريه
منذ الانقلاب حتى الان وليس الصحفيين فقط
نعم في هذه الحاله سيد محمد محسوب هل
تعتقد بان ربما ربما التصرف التصرف الذكي
الان هو ان يقع ربما التضحيه بوزير
الداخليه الاقدام على افراج واسع على
هؤلاء الصحفيين حتى لا تتدحرج الكره اكثر
في هذه العلاقه السيئه مع
الصحفيين يعني هو ربما لو جرت تضحيه معبد
الفتاح السيسي يمكن يعني اصلاح العلاقه
الحقيقه يا سيدي المشكله احنا لسنا امام
اخطاء ترتكبها بعض ادوات السلطه ولا جهات
السلطه ابدا احنا امام سياسه واضحه منذ
انقلاب 3/7 20103 حتى اليوم هذا الانقلاب
مستمر في تدمير كل افق سياسي وتدمير كافه
اسس الحقوق والحريات للشعب المصري بدات
يعني بمذابح هائله وما يجد هو استمرار
لهذه المذابح مذابح للحقوق والحريات كما
جرت مذابح لقوى المعارضه وبالتالي اذا كان
البعض سيتناولها باعتبارها اخطاء فسينتج
30 سنه اخرى ليتبين له الحقيقه انها كانت
سياسه واضحه اذا ادرك منذ الان انها سياسه
واضحه ربما يتغير اشخاص الوزراء ربما
يتغير رئيس الوزاره ربما يتغير مدير الامن
او الامن الوطني او ما شابه لكن السياسه
كل هذه ادوات في لتحقيق سياسه واحده فسي
درك انه لو كان بيقر بان النظام القائم هو
نظام ا ليس انقلابي وان الرئيس هو رئيس
وان السلطه هي السلطه فسيطلب بان ترحل وان
تاتي وينتخب سلطه جديده واذا كان مثلنا
يؤمن بانها منذ البدايه بلا شرعيه ومنذ
البدايه انقلاب سيطالب وسيعمل على اسقاطها
لا بديل لذلك يا سيدي شكرا لك سيد محمد
محسوب وزير الشؤون القانونيه والبرلمانيه
المصري السابق شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من
القاهره المحامي والباحث السياسي اسعد
هيكل ونقيب الصحفيين المصريين الاسبق
ممدوح
الولي في امان
[موسيقى]
الله